the philadelphia eagles are at the point
where they need to really go back to
square one chris and try to determine
why it is that so many of their guys get
injured rookie receiver jalen rieger
first round pick out three to four weeks
with a torn labrum that's just the
latest it seems like every day there's
another injury to an eagles player who
otherwise would be part of the starting
lineup or close to it yeah in 2020 and
yesterday the big news on top of rieger
carson wentz day-to-day with a lower
body injury now this isn't hockey this
is just the kind of stuff that the nfl
can get away with prior to week one they
didn't even have to tell us lower body
they don't have to tell us day to day
all they have to say is he's not at
practice next wednesday in advance of
week one against washington we'll find
out if wence practices we'll find out
what part of the lower body it is they
can't be that general it's gonna be
ankle it's gonna be foot it's gonna be
knee it's gonna be calf it's to be
something lower body unless they're
lying now and again there's nothing that
keeps them from lying now there's no
rules right now but let's assume they're
telling the truth there's some sort of
day-to-day lower body injury for carson
wentz i mean let's let's start with him
and then we'll circle back to rieger uh
you know last year wence went wired a
wire
he was the only guy i think on the
offense that went wire to wire and he
ended up being a huge contributor down
the stretch with a bunch of no names
around him if he misses time there's no
nick foles there to save the day it's
nate sudfeld right it's jalen hurts i
mean they they they may be
a mess it's night night it is night
night unless he's there i mean look
we're right back where we were last year
i mean what are we talking about left
tackles hurt
jason peters who's signed back to play
guard because one of the best guards in
football and brandon brooks he was hurt
now we're talking about jason peters
might have to move to left tackle and
let me just remind everybody jason
peters hasn't been able to stay healthy
the last three years himself either so
that's an issue then miles sanders is
hurt and then alshon joffrey's not back
yet and now jalen rieger's gone and it's
like whoa i mean
i mean week one's already looking like
hey carson's gonna have to tell
everybody to jump on their on his back
and he's gonna have to carry the team
already here on the offensive side of
the ball if he's not there capable of
playing
forget it good night no way i just said
there's no way i just don't see that
happening that's a huge blow with the
jalen rieger injury and andre diller
being heard at left tackle certainly but
you know here we are i mean again we're
desean jackson who we know who is yeah
he could still fly and all that but he's
had injury issues too the last few years
we're one post route away from him
hurting a calf muscle or a hamstring and
then going wait who the hell is playing
receiver for the eagles this year so i
mean they are dancing on thin ice right
now and it it's the big thing
coven 19 is the battle we know that the
other battle
is teams trying to keep their guys
healthy you know and we have some teams
that see just seem to be
wow i mean dropping like flies compared
to others and i'd be really interested
to know what they're doing or i know
some of it's bad luck but it's just it's
amazing right now
and ricker's injury happened when he
tried to make a tackle yeah after an
interception that was thrown by jalen
hurts it was hurt's first throw of a
scrimmage they had yesterday you know
this is that balance like do you tell
your receivers right and your other
offensive players if there's a turnover
during a scrimmage just stop like what's
the point i know you really need to
practice tackling a guy uh when he's
trying to return a turnover during a
game i don't know where that balance is
it's a tough one but
you see you see what can happen yeah
when guys who don't tackle for a living
decide they're going to try to go throw
a tackle during his scrimmage and you
know adrenaline kicks in as well exactly
kicks in but right now he's out out for
a few weeks three to four weeks with
this tour in labor because he tried to
make a tackle during a scrimmage that
was ultimately meaningless yeah a torn
labrum too yeah he'll be out three to
four weeks and yeah he can come back
then it doesn't mean he's gonna be a
hundred percent he's gonna have to this
this is the type of injury that's just
gonna bother you all year every time he
catches a screen pass and somebody lands
on him wrong he's gonna have to come out
of the game because he's like oh damn my
shoulder hurts i mean that's that's what
stinks about this injury it's very
easily to reoccur
uh but you're right mike it's a very
fine line getting back to what you're
talking about because these coaches
right now
yeah we're we're ten days away two weeks
away from real football tackle football
offenses are gonna throw interceptions
so you do want your guys to get used to
like hey oh lyman you know we got a
break on the ball we gotta go get this
guy receiver we gotta go we gotta go get
him and then you're right the pride
factor sets in here's a rookie he's
trying to show hey i'm tough i'm a
football player trying to do all the
right things which you know i give him
credit for and that happens and you know
he's just not ready yet so
uh i don't know i mean i
i'm feeling bad about the eagles already
right now it's making me think
differently about how their season's
gonna start off uh when we i think we
both thought they were gonna be very
strong and one of the better teams in
football
at what point do we say there's a deeper
issue i'm no expert in sports medicine
or athletic training but i know that
just over the years you'll see different
hot spots where it seems like it's more
than just luck of the draw it's more
than just random and i know from sitting
next to rodney harrison in the screening
room at nbc for the past 10 years and he
has this uncanny ability to spot while
watching nine games at once the
potentially serious knee injury that
causes him to smack me across the chest
and say watch this replay and 9 out of
10 times the guy who gets twisted into a
human pretzel who looks like he is not
going to go off the field on anything
but a cart gets up and walks away and
that that tells me that number one
there's a much greater degree of
flexibility in younger people than older
people but some of these teams know
exactly how to get these guys in the
kind of condition right the kind of
shape the kind of malleability that
allows them to get pretzeled around like
that and not get injured so what are the
teams doing wrong remember when chip
kelly was a coach in philly and it was
the personalized smoothies to help guard
against injury something's wrong there
so it's not it can't just be bad luck to
have this many injuries i i mean mike
i'm with you i think that's very you
know real question to ask there when it
starts to become commonplace two three
years in a row
you know i always go well man
you know bad luck okay yeah there could
be some of that
but i would think either training or the
approach to practice is not correct at
this point you know i think that's what
we're probably seeing from a lot of
these teams right now that got guys
falling like flies you know are they are
they being over aggressive with the
intensity of practice trying to make up
for lost time and knowing that we got a
game two weeks from now
all i know is
i'm not hearing very many injuries up in
new england that's all i know and that's
where my that's my baseline always
that's always my baseline
because
the area i mean i don't know we don't
i'm not hearing lower body injuries or
guys falling like flies up in new
england bill's obviously realized
something about the way it is right now
and what the way to practice not over
tax your guys that way uh so this is
something that's very real yeah
battling the kova 19 pandemic as we saw
anthony lynn saying hard knocks is going
to be a big part of the super bowl
you know
managing your football team and getting
them in the proper shape and making sure
they don't like drop out you know with
huge numbers of guys weekly from
injuries that's another huge battle here
as we go into week one
i think the key is avoiding the panic
that comes from uncertainty right we've
got limited practices we've got no
preseason games how in the hell am i
going to evaluate my roster how am i
going to get my team ready well the only
way to evaluate my roster is to pit man
against man and see who the best guys
are and and i just think that you know
and i think we've all been there when we
are facing a challenge that we regard as
daunting
one of the
one of the easiest ways to proceed is
full speed ahead no questions asked
let's go let's go attack this thing yeah
and and when you do that you're going to
get guys injured right you do that in
football guys are going to get injured
if your attitude and if your way of
dealing with it is let's just go out
there and iron sharpen iron and go beat
the hell out of each other and see who's
standing and we're going to find out who
the toughest guys are that way no
no you're going to get guys injured
there's got to be a better way to
separate wheat from chaff and get your
roster down to 53 and figure out who the
16 practice squad players are going to
be without without making those
decisions a hell of a lot more easy
because all those guys that would
otherwise be on the fringes are injured
chris yeah no i i think it is real well
and you know i also look at the eagles a
little bit like the 49ers in a lot of
ways where i just go i think they got a
lot of psychos on that team and i mean
that in a good way to where
i think you probably got to govern them
a little bit as far as practice is
concerned if you just let them go live
to live
you know that they go crazy they're
gonna run through walls they're gonna
kill each other they don't care it's
it's the the game the the type of
players and personalities these teams
have you know accumulated and
philadelphia i do feel like is one of
those type of places that's why they are
good they're fun to watch they lay their
body on the line they throw their bodies
all over the place that's why they won
the super bowl but yeah uh it's it's you
got there's a fine line there and
guarding your players from themselves a
little bit to where you know they can't
like step off the gas pedal in certain
situations and whoa we can't do that my
guys aren't capable they're gonna go
full speed and someone's gonna get hurt
left tackle andre dillard first round
pick last year was injured recently and
doug peterson the coach of the team
rattled off a bunch of different names a
bunch of different candidates and one of
them is jason peters who was brought
back
to play guard after brandon brooks went
down for the year
and peters is getting a three million
dollar base salary he can make another
three million on top of it and he
reportedly wants more if he's getting
moved a left tackle and i've seen some
people saying well how dare you you
can't do that you can't have you can't
you can't ask for more more money to
change yes you can if you were brought
in to play guard and the discussion was
you're coming in to play guard and for
all we know there was a conversation hey
if you're going to move them to tackle
this is a different this is a different
analysis all together i mean left
tackle's a more valuable position and
you're more exposed you're more on an
island right if you make a mistake at
guard it it isn't as obvious as when you
get your ass beat at left tackle and
those are all reasons that make that a
more valuable position chris yeah i mean
yeah oh hey great i got a job in senior
management hey great job hey now we're
going to make you the president now well
i don't want any more money or not
anything like that i know i'm the
president and running the you know the
company now but well yeah of course he
signed up to play guard you're right
it's a totally different animal guard
you got help around you you know you got
a tackle in the center on both sides of
you it's not always one-on-one uh the
tackle is a it's that's a whole
different landscape as far as what's
expected of you the importance of that
job and i understand that and i think
that's why we're hearing the eagles
you know at first here i think they
realize what they're dealing with
they're they're going to try other
people at left tackle over jason peters
and try to keep jason peters at right
guard and deal with that and see if
somebody else can't fill in the position
of andre dillard probably because they
don't want to deal with the headache
right now of having to give jason peters
you know three five million extra
dollars or whatever to play left tackle
and they're going to just hold their
breath and assume he's not going to get
in right i mean once they start dropping
you just you just brace yourself for the
next one and you're not even in the
games yet
where and there's not even preseason
games these are practice injuries it's
amazing to me but it's not because we
had to assume going in we're gonna have
a mixed bag you're gonna have new
england with no word of anyone injured
you're going to have other teams where
maybe they are beating the crap out of
each other i mean the 49ers have had a
ton of injuries they've got those
roughnecks out there
that don't that don't need to be that's
the thing they don't need to be
practicing tackling to the ground they
can tackle the ground in their sleep and
uh and again we don't know the
circumstances of every injury right but
when you see a cluster
you have to ask yourself
is this something other than just bad
luck and sometimes it is bad luck
but i think it's incumbent on the
organization coaching staff front office
everyone at some point to take a step
back and say why is this happening
because obviously this isn't conducive
to getting the best possible team ready
to go to win as many games as they can
no you know
it's going to be part of the struggle
throughout the year because yeah again
let's not forget
after week one
i i think they're going to have record
numbers inside training rooms and as far
as guys that need rehab oh my ankle oh
my shoulder you know like you said
they're not even conditioned here for
for full contact practice let alone you
know in two weeks we're going to be torn
all up and flying around like crazy men
crushing each other so
that's gonna be a big part managing
bodies especially this month of
september as everybody gets into
football shape and deals with getting
banged up and deals with oh this is what
it feels like to play injured and and do
all those things uh a bigger part of the
season as any i've ever seen or
certainly in this season that's for sure
yeah and uh 13 days until the first full
sunday and just
10 days until the texans and the chiefs
get together had to stop and think had
to think monday thursday 7 8 9 10 days
10 days for the texans and the chiefs on
a special edition of sunday night
football on the first thursday night to
kick off the season and raise the banner
and celebrate the championship in kansas
city with about 16 000 fans there and
those tickets are going for a pretty
penny because everybody in kansas city
wants to be there to witness that event
unfortunately we won't be there we'll be
watching it on tv like everyone else all
right let's take a break we won't be
watching one of the best college
receivers in
the country play this year but not
because he's in a conference that isn't
playing and not because he's concerned
about cove but we'll tell you why jamar
chase is standing down for 2020 when pft
live continues right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports